hey guys this is andrew for
trainsenses.com so as you know i have
now more time
so i can do more updates and i think
that today i already made an update on
gamestop and amc
and another very interesting market i
should make an update on
is the bitcoin gas because we have the
strong move done that we're
actually expecting so let's get into it
[Music]
and guys so let me quickly remind you as
usual what i was saying in my last video
so in my last video i was telling you
that i was basically spotting
two different information the first
information is that here
the market after the correction that i
told you guys would happen around
mid april that you know did an abc here
and failed
to do four and five so it was a three
waves move and not the fives
wave move so this was the first
information i had in the update i made
last week guys so bitcoin was trading
around 40 000
so i told you that this is the first
information for me that
on the long term we are bullish but on
the short term i was telling you guys
that i was spawning
bearish hidden divergence all right so
once again you have few types of
divergences
the one i was putting last time was this
one so basically
the momentum indicator got going higher
so usually the market
should make a new high but the market
was failing to make this new high
so this is what we call a bearish hidden
divergence so once again guys
let me remind you i use divergences a
lot that they are not 100
trustful signals i mean you know usually
when you have a divergence just alone by
itself
it's gonna give you the right direction
of the market depending on the time
frame you're considering but let's say
you know if you use the four hours time
frame
you can say that basically by next week
or in the next couple of days
the market is going to trade lower with
a primary of
i would say not just divergence by
itself 70
something like this so here i had this
divergence
and also had 42 000 level
that was a strong resistance area so i
had basically two
information that were telling me that
the bitcoin would probably trade lower
next week
and this is what happened then i
associate this
analysis with elliot wave analysis once
again i told you that here we have only
an abc
so the only way for me to label this
complex correction that is happening
is by doing more abcs so once again
i don't you know take this from my mind
guys this is coming from elliot wave a
theory book that is here
written by frost and presto and you can
see here
elliot called sideways combination of
corrective patterns double threes and
triple threads so basically
three is an abc you know there are three
waves so we call it the three
a triangle is also a three while a
single three is any zigzag flat a
triangle is an
allowable final component of such
combinations and
is in this context called a three so
this is looking like this you have abc
abc and for example abcde this is the
typical sideways
correction that uh is gonna be
actually a combination of corrective
patterns and this is i think what we're
having on the bitcoin and this is what i
told you guys already
last week right so i told you we are
bearish i told you we probably
gonna go to the 30 000 area again so i
just kept my drawing guys
you can go and check you know my
previous video once again guys in my
technical analysis
i will not be 100 right all right this
is not possible
trading is about probabilities and
expected gains like i was saying
here i was right some other times i
might be wrong
but what is important is to understand
each time why you were right or
why you were wrong so you're gonna keep
doing what is working and you're gonna
correct what was not working
this is training so we having abc
abc so now we have basically three
scenarios either we do an abcd
like this so i just kept my drawings
otherwise we're gonna do a flat
you know that's possible as well
a flat and then it's gonna come from
here so second scenario
so in both scenarios as you can see guys
we bounce back here
third scenario we do a zigzag
and then we break okay so in this
scenario
we go to the next level all right where
is the next level guys once again
if you use elgatwave theory this is very
helpful because the next level is just
the top of the third wave
all right either it's the bottom of the
force wave like we're having right now
like 30 000 or is the the top of the
third wave which is 20 000
and i don't know if you can see it here
but we have a beautiful
head and shoulder pattern right here
shoulder head shoulder
all right so this is the neckline
here if we break the neckline guys
usually
we make this move so from here to here
which is 20 000 down all right okay so
basically we go to 5 000 which is not
possible
so this won't be happening here but if
we break this we definitely go to 20
000. we might
even maybe not reach it there are so
many
buyers between 20 and 25 so many buyers
so that are waiting for the 20 000 to be
re-tested
this was the major resistance level a
few years ago guys
let me have a look here on the monthly
time frame
so this level has not been retested so
many buyers are waiting
for this level to be retested to enter a
long trade on the bitcoin
i don't think we're gonna reach that
level i don't think so because there are
too many buyers between 20 and 25 you
know they just want to
front run each other so i don't think
we're gonna go that low guys let me go
back to my drawings
okay so here careful this head and
shoulder if we break the neckline
on the first time frame we will probably
go to the 20
20 000 area maybe 22 i don't know
something around here
this would be actually my third scenario
which is the abc
here is actually deeper and in any case
guys in any case
all right so we have three scenarios
either we do a triangle here
and then basically end of july we start
the strong move up
or we do a zigzag and end of july we
start to do strong move up sorry
flat or we do a zigzag so then we go to
the twenty thousand area
so in my three scenarios we are bouncing
back
from thirty thousand so let's see what
would happen here but i think we're
going to bounce back to the 35 000
area and then there's going to be a
question but even if we break the 30 000
area careful guys this would probably be
very quick
you would need to be very reactive to
get into this trade at this level so
maybe prepare
your orders if you want to get into this
trade and then we're gonna have this one
two three four five so once again
you're gonna have the second wave if you
want to enter this trade so you have
time
if you want to take a long position once
again i don't give her financial advice
but what i i would do
i would buy the dip around the 2025 area
i would buy the dip around the 30 000
area as well i would have a stop loss
around the 28 000 area
and then i would use this one two to
enter my trade or i would
wait for the triangle to come and i
would play the breakout of the triangle
you know it would look like something
like this if we have a triangle
here we're gonna have a clear breakout
that you can use to enter the trade
if it's a flat it's going to be the same
and if it's a zigzag you need to buy the
dip
i mean i would buy the dip i will keep
updating you guys
on the bitcoin i have one more thing i
wanted to show you guys is that right
now we're having
a bullish exaggerated divergence so now
the market is unable to make a new low
with the macd going higher all right
unable to make a new low
we bottom that 30 000 again with the
macd going higher so we have a bullish
exaggerated divergence once again the
exaggerated divergence are less powerful
than the
hidden or regular divergences so let's
be careful
let's say that there is still a
possibility that we break 30 000 but to
me it's quite
unlikely now that's it for me so i hope
you guys enjoyed this video and if you
did please don't forget to click on the
sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys